pub
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas le temps d'admirer le paysage des
bolides sont déjà partis le prince
rainier la princesse grèce ont eu juste
le temps de les voir démarrer chaque
année dans l'état ainsi à monaco pour
une journée en effet la ville
n'appartient plus qu'aux voitures de
course et parfois aux artistes cette
course est placée cette année sous le
signe de l' incident mécanique
anachronisme à gijon lotus numéro 22
pouces sa voiture pour être classé lens
caen continue de rouler à vive allure
sur le circuit stirling moss lathus
climax numéro 28 a pris la tête pendant
que loin derrière lui on se livre à une
chute spectaculaire
et c'est sans aucune espèce de
difficulté que stirling moss a triomphé
en démontrant la supériorité actuelle
des voitures de cause britannique sur
les voitures italiennes
[Applaudissements]
louison bobet en tête il est treize
concurrents de bordeaux paris commence
en pleine nuit leur long calvaire qui va
durer près de 16 heures 16 heures sans
descendre de bicyclette au cours
desquelles ils vont manger et boire la
ration d'une semaine pour un homme
normal
chatellerault tout le monde descend tout
le monde continue plus exactement mais
derrière entraîneur
louison bobet semble prêt à renouveler
son exploit de l'an dernier et voici
vendôme où le peloton est encore groupé
et puis bouvet l'homme courageux
s'échappe beaucoup trop tôt le belge
janssen se rattrape sur place tout le
monde et termine seul au parc des
princes avec plus de quatre minutes
d'avancé sur le français françois mail
ob termine 4e
[Musique]
au chili ou huit jours après le terrible
tremblement de terre les secousses
telluriques continue de se faire sentir
chassant les habitants des dernières
maisons restées debout le bilan de la
catastrophe n'est toujours que
provisoire de conception à chiloé ce ne
sont que scènes de désespoir villes et
villages sont en ruine et ces images ne
peuvent rendre compte de l'étendue
géographique du désastre qui a frappé
des provinces entières
on a avancé des chiffres 2800 morts plus
de 800 disparus
mais ces chiffres vont sans doute être
dépassé
[Musique]
et dans l'incertitude du lendemain le
chili compte un million de sans abri
[Musique]
mais là ne s'arrête pas le désastre
un violent raz-de-marée provoqué par le
séisme a éprouvé les pays riverains du
pacifique
c'est ainsi qu'à quelques 650 kilomètres
à l'heure la vague a déferlé sur îlots
seconde ville des îles hawaï qu'elle a
transformé en un champ de des comptes au
premier bilan
le 50e état des états unis comptait 33
morts 27 disparus
une soixantaine de blessés
sur la côte japonaise la conséquence du
raz-de-marée qui a emporté les bateaux
et ravagé départ a été plus lourde
encore des milliers de maisons détruites
des centaines de blessés officiellement
99 morts
[Musique]
mir activité politique à tokyo autour du
traité de sécurité américano japonais
4000 manifestants contenus par 3000
policiers avaient bloqué les abords du
parlement où après l'expulsion des
députés de l'opposition socialiste
devait être votée la ratification dans
les couloirs les députés de l'opposition
s'était mise en tête d'empêcher le
président de la diète d'accéder à son
fauteuil pour ouvrir la séance
surprenante activités parlementaires
voici l'entrée du président monsieur qui
osent et qui a fait quelque peu les
frais d'une opération qui s'est soldé
par 60 blessés
[Musique]
finalement ses amis parvint à le hisser
jusqu'à son fauteuil d'où il put agrippé
au micro déclaré la séance ouverte
moyennant quoi les 260 députés restants
votèrent la ratification
toute l'algérie a été appelé aux urnes
les élections cantonales voulu par le
général de gaulle était à la fois un
test est un témoignage test de liberté
et témoignages de volonté et malgré les
menaces du fln malgré les campagnes
d'intimidation et la multiplication des
actes terroristes l'algérie de l'est à
l'ouest à voter en général la
participation électorale s'est établi
autour de 55% et pour les deux tiers des
votants a montré que l'algérie
s'affirmer d'accord avec les idées du 16
septembre et le soutien au général de
gaulle ces images prises aussi bien dans
leur annexe dans l'algérois montre que
le bled ne s'est pas enfermé dans un
attentisme créatif le bled à bouger mais
l'exemple type est peut-être la kabylie
pourtant éternel foyers d'agitation et
dans les collines sont depuis le début
l'un des centres de la rébellion
là où n'avait pu avoir lieu les
élections municipales les élections
cantonales ont pris l'alluré d'une
véritable compétition démocratique et
c'est en pleine lumière qu'on peut
aujourd'hui parler d'une victoire de la
kabylie évolué sur la kabylie
traditionnels
dans son compte rendu au peuple
américain de la conférence manqué le
président eisenhower a montré des photos
de l'aérodrome de san diego
prise à vingt mille mètres d'altitude la
netteté extraordinaire de ces documents
a démontré la nécessité d'un système
efficace d'information relativement aux
possibilités militaire de nation
puissante en particulier de celles qui
ont la manie du secret dans le même
temps monsieur qu'abbott lodge délégué
américain aux nations unies faisait
devant le conseil de sécurité en réponse
à la plainte touchant l'avion espion
une démonstration des méthodes
d'espionnage utilisé par les sommiers à
l'appui ils découvraient les secrets
d'un cadeau fait par les russes à
l'ambassade américaine de moscou joli
panneau de bois aux armes des états unis
et renfermant un écouteur radio qui
permettait d'entendre les conversations
de l'ambassadeur la guerre des espions
n'a jamais cessé
[Musique]
c'est à ce moment aussi que l'armée
américaine procédait au lancement d'un
satellite espion dont le nom est tout un
programme
midas placé sur une orbite à 400 km de
la terre midas qui pèse près de deux
tonnes et demie est chargé de détecter
les fusées intercontinentales
dès leur départ mission de défense
uniquement mais on voit que la guerre
des espions n'est pas en perte de
vitesse
[Musique]
voici un an environ je m'intéresse chef
du gouvernement turc est l objet des
acclamations populaire aujourd'hui il
est arrêté
la vague de fond qui ont emporté
m'intéresse ramène au jour la figure 10
mai thi nonu compagnon d'atatürk et son
successeur jusqu'en 1950 son exclusion
du parlement voici un mois marqua le
début des troubles qui devait aboutir au
coup d'état d'aujourd'hui ces images
prises de la tourelle d'un char évoque
les manifestations quotidiennes que
l'armée fut appelée à réprimer mais
l'armée s'est érigé en arbitre et a
balayé le régime de m'intéresse l'armée
elle est depuis la première guerre
mondiale une puissance considérable
c'est elle qui derrière atatürk
reconquis le pays après 1918 restera
l'état assure à la transformation de la
vieille turquie en nation jeunes aux
mains de ce constructeur d'un 1 9l pris
sa forme et sa puissante la politique
des dernières décades fixe a son
importance à ce poste dangereux qui est
la limite est le contact des mondes de
l'est et de l'ouest
gardiennes des détroits elle assure à
istanbul la permanence d'un équilibre
construit par cinq siècles de vie
européenne gardienne des frontières du
monde libre elles montent la garde au
flanc du caucase comme lisière
macédonienne le rue de soldats turcs a
la réputation d'un soldat exemplaire
multipliaient 600 mille unités pour un
peuple de 25 millions d'âmes c'est la
proportion la plus forte du monde
instruits par l'occident et équipés d
armes les plus modernes il compose une
armée que les experts tiennent pour
l'une des forces les plus authentiques
de l'otan c'est cette armée derrière
gürsel qui a pris le pouvoir elle se
défend de vouloir le garder et ne
prétend qu'ouvrir la voie à un
gouvernement plus démocrate
[Musique]
à istanbul comme ankara la foule a bien
accueilli la nouvelle du coup d'état
partout l'armée est acclamé et
encourager la promesse d'élections
libres
la fin d'un régime qui s'appuyait sur
des méthodes autoritaires annonce des
changements mais non des bouleversements
et le premier mot du nouveau pouvoir a
été pour dire que la turquie entendait
reste fidèle à l'alliance atlantique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]